hi in this video we'll talk about
vitamin a vitamin a is a fat-soluble
vitamin and vitamin A is derived from
carrots catch is the major source of
vitamin A among the vegetables and other
than carrots there is cheese eggs papaya
bell peppers pumpkin avocado and even
from fish we can derive vitamin A now
vitamin A the main pro-vitamin for
vitamin A is beta carotene beta carotene
is derived from carrot now this bitter
carotene is processed in several ways
let us understand the structure of beta
carotene it has 2 beta onion rings
marked in this red circle and it has a
poly preneur chain which is joining
these 2 beta onion rings
now these poly preneur chain would be
cleaved and somatically in specific
region to give rise to retinol now this
is basically vitamin A so from one beta
carotene essentially two molecules of
vitamin A can be produced now vitamin A
can be converted or interconverted in
two different formats like from retinol
and retinyl the interchange with each
other and from retinol it is a one-way
conversion to retinoic acid retina we
can see the super important signaling
molecule important for several
physiological processes which we would
not talk about in this video
now let's say we eat a carrot and see
from this scanner how the vermin a is
absorbed and processed by our digestive
system and how it is mobilized and how
it is utilized by our body so when we
eat the carrot it is getting digested
and the beta-carotene is getting somehow
metabolized into the intestine now
inside the intestine the beta-carotene
would be cleaved or let's say further
processed by an enzyme known as dioxygen
is which would creep Pyrrhic a turn
character
and ultimately give rise to ready now
right now this red nail is packed in my
sillies and from that it is absorbed
along with the fat in the intestinal
villi x' now from there it goes to the
liver inside the liver and inside the
liver cells it is stored in a format of
retinol palmitate now whenever it is
required is released in the blood and
with specific retinol binding protein
which serves as a carrier it is
transported into the various location of
the body where between a is required now
when I mean a is super important for
vision and for next few moments we would
spend our time to understand how vitamin
A is so important for vision and what
happens when in case of vitamin
deficiency so here is our eye and we
know at the back of our eye the main
screen which helps to display the images
our retina inside the retina there are
several kind of cells like rod cell cone
cells rod cells give us sensitivity
towards low light whereas cone cells
help in color vision now we talked about
rod cells inside the rod cells there is
the main pigment called rhodopsin
rhodopsin is nothing but a g-protein
coupled receptor now this rhodopsin
inside this rhodopsin it has a
structural unit which is nothing but
vitamin A derived retinol 11 it emits
ena 11 sis format when there is absolute
dark situation when light falls on these
rhodopsin it undergoes a conformational
change 11 sees retina becomes all trans
retinal and this conformational change
has consequences now due to the
conformational change in rhodopsin RG
protein associated with rhodopsin which
is known as transducing gets activated
now once transducing is activated as it
is a GS kind of signalling regime
G alpha subunit gets dissociated from
these complex and move in a
membrane-bound fashion and activates a
particular phosphodiester is known as
cyclic GMP phosphodiesterase now what
does cyclic jane before that diaster is
to as the name suggests it will convert
cyclic GMP to an one cyclic form but
what's the consequence of that normally
what happens when there is absolute dark
there is a lot of sodium entry from
cyclic nucleotide gated channel and
cyclic nucleotide gated channel click
where cyclic team before their operation
now when there is light what happens is
the cyclic GMP phosphodiester is is
activated via this transducing molecule
and transducing is itself activated by
light so a lot of cyclic GMP which is
important for the channel activity of
cyclic nucleotide gated channel is now
getting converted to GMP and that's how
the cyclic nucleotide gated channel is
no more open and this change lead to
electrical change in the rod cells which
bring about or which which kind of
transduce the signal to the higher order
neurons of the visual system and that's
how we can see now vitamin A deficiency
leads to several situations like Nick
tilapia syrup Tawnia etc Nick tilapia
means nine blindness so normally these
rod cells are super important for
low-light vision and they gives us
sensitivity for visualizing things in
low-light now and normal circumstances
this is how your eye look like but in
case of nine plainness your level of
these vitamin a is already deficient and
that's why too much rhodopsin is not
functional it's difficult to see under
low-light situation second condition is
sera - Mia well there is a dryness
of the conjunctiva conjunctivitis
becomes dry thick and wrinkled not only
that the con young t writer gets
keratinized and loses its normal
transparency and the dryness spreads all
over the cornea right here you can see
there is opaque structure or opacity is
developed in the specific region of
these cornea
now when when the rock tell Mia persist
for a very long time it leads to carrot
of Molossia
which is even severe format of that in
that what happens is there's a softness
of cornea and people often use the term
that cornea is melting down opposite
ativ loves corneal infection is
increased and there is overall a huge
problem in the eyesight and in chronic
crisis there could be absolute blindness
other than that vitamin A has very
important roles in terms of maintaining
the integrity of the skin cells and skin
cell production in absence of firming a
skin cells become very dry and there are
skin blemishes and this kind of
phenomena is like very similar to a dry
and rugged skin of a toad which is free
no drama and the scientific name of this
stood indian toad is known as a friend
or dharma and that's why this disease is
known as free neuroma now other than
these kind of effects vitamin a is found
to be very important for maintenance of
repair and maintenance of the skin these
are also important in differentiation of
stem cells and other tissue
differentiation formats it has been
shown by several medical studies that
having good amount of vitamin A in your
diet every day lowers the risk of your
heart attack and definitely when I mean
a is a very good antioxidant and it
reduced the harmful effect of superoxide
hydroxyl or peroxide radicals in that
respect vitamin A is super important for
our own body's metabolism
and proper functioning of our body now
let's talk about a little about how we
can understand that vitamin A deficiency
happens there are some easy ways that
you can also do and there are like
biochemical tests for that so one easy
way of detecting vitamin A deficiency is
dark adaptation test imagine a situation
when you are coming from a light room to
a dark room you immediately adopt right
and you can see start seeing things in
dark as well because your rod cells are
now active and they give you the
sensitivity towards the low light
situation so in this test same thing has
been done let's say you are you can see
this object in a light room and suddenly
you're transferred to another room which
is absolutely dark and then the time is
counted to which you can see the things
inside the dark room properly now in
case of vitamin A deficiency this time
is prolonged than a normal situation
other than that what people do is
measure the level of retinal binding
protein since it's a fat soluble vitamin
it is not going to be present in the
blood in free format it is always come
conjugated with retinal binding protein
and also directly detecting the freedom
in a level in serum is also another way
in case of deficiency the sinem level
falls below 25 microgram per deciliter
I mean this is the normal level of a
vitamin A and it falls way below that
and that is how we can understand
vitamin A deficiency happened so in this
video in this 10 minutes we have really
covered sources of vitamin metabolism of
vitamin functions of filming a
deficiencies that are associated with
vitamin a diagnosis of vitamin A
deficiency etc so I hope you enjoyed
this video if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe and do let me
know how you like my videos in the
comment section and your feedback is
really valuable and it would help me to
improve the content thank you